good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is Ingram angle from Washington
tonight still winning that's the focus
of tonight's
Angle now our nation's billionaires did
not get rich and Powerful because they
love to make bad Investments they got
rich and Powerful because they've made
good Investments and at least one
high-profile Nikki Haley donor has
decided she's a bad investment we
learned today that LinkedIn founder Reed
Hoffman a Biden supporter and Haley
backer announced that he's ending his
support for her after her double digit
New Hampshire loss also more bad news
for Nikki a republican fundraiser told
CNBC on Wednesday that three clients who
each helped Haley raise up to $100,000
for the campaign are now opting out of
assisting her so this bad fundraising
news followed Haley's pitiful postlaw
spinorama today we got close to half of
the vote this race is far far from over
there are dozens of States left to go
with Donald Trump you have one bout of
chaos after another this court case that
controversy this tweet I've long called
for mental competency tests for
politicians over the age of 75 he should
have no problem standing on a debate
stage with me the first party to retire
its 80-year-old candidate is going to be
the party that wins this
election now now this is simply very
shortsighted on haly's part now she
might not have liked our advice for the
past week to drop out of the race but
it's been accurate the angle's advice on
this has turned out to be 100% on spot
now if she keeps on this path she's
going to convince people that she's a
bush Cheney Republican and then her
career will really be over now everyone
needs to understand this how significant
Trump's New Hampshire win was to give
you some historical perspective in 1980
Reagan lost the Iowa caucuses in 88
George HW Bush lost the Iowa caucuses in
2000 George W bush lost the New
Hampshire Primary in 2016 remember Trump
lost the Iowa caucuses but this year
Trump won both Iowa and New Hampshire
even though the governors in both of
those States opposed him and even though
his opposition outspend him in both
States it's a tremendous Victory and it
shows the extent to which Republican
voters Trust on the issues the BBC's
headline it's Trump's party now and then
Fox uh voter analysis showed that
Haley's only got 28% of registered
Republicans
28% 70% voted for Donald Trump now
that's because a good chunk of Haley's
votes come from self-proclaimed
moderates or from people who changed
their party registration to vote for her
a couple of months ago now these voters
did not show up because they're wild
about Nikki they didn't vote for her
because they're wild about her oh yeah
Nikki no they showed up because they
want to stop Trump I voted for Nikki
haly and it was certainly a strategic
vote and while I wouldn't vote for her
in a general election particularly on
our differences with uh climate change
solution and women's right to bodily
autonomy I think a vote for Nikki Haley
is helps diminish Trump's influence why
did you vote for Nikki Haley uh it's a
vote against Trump if it was Nikki Haley
against Joe Biden in a general election
who are you voting for Joe
Biden how I mean it's just sad this
point for her to run around the country
carrying water for the people who
despise the GOP base as her frenetic
surrogates desperately try to convince
you that her collapse is not inevitable
two states down 48 to go it's only
become a one-on-one race uh literally in
in the past couple weeks she's really
ramped up the attacks on him let's face
it he's effectively the incumbent
president so that's a hard Hill to climb
to for sure but she's but every time
there's a hill in Nikki Haley's way she
climbs it she knocks it down she pushes
everybody out of the race she's got one
more Hill to climb and that's to beat
that's to beat Trump in her home
state man I think it's time to switch to
decaf now even Politico is reporting now
what we've been saying for weeks if
Haley thinks her home state will deliver
her first win it's highly unlikely she's
cruising toward Jeb bushville any
momentum Haley can claim out of New
Hampshire runs into daunting polls and
an expensive month-long campaign to
reverse them in a state where if not for
her connections should likely have
little chance of success now other
Republicans have challenged Trump and
have gone on to remain very influential
and extremely well respected there's a
certain amount of space in which
everyone in a party can disagree on
issues so people like Ted Cruz is going
to join us in a few moments Marco Rubio
ran Paul and Ronda santis they all did
that but if the voters think that you're
truly against them and on the side of
Liz Cheney and the Never trumpers they
will never forgive you oh and it's not
true by the way that Republicans who you
know have to step aside need to bow down
to Trump that's just a media creation
forget about that but the more that
Haley takes big money from Trump haters
the more she repeats Democrat talking
points about his mental Fitness or his
you know perceived to look down on Trump
and his voters the harder it's going to
be for her to find her way back to the
Republican party which I think she
ultimately wants to go back to now just
listen to the loudest voices begging her
to stay in the race for Nikki Haley
there's only one way through this
there's a I mean there's light way down
there at the end of the tunnel you keep
going uh and and maybe you don't win
outright but you win a war of attrition
if you're the donor class that wants
Trump gone you tell her thuck it out for
a few months I'm going to put some more
money in your bank
account did she say Thug it out yes she
did now I actually have more respect for
joy re than the other guy who spoke
before her in that little
Montage now even Texas moderate John
Corin has decided to give up the dream
of someone other than Trump last night
he said that he's seen enough and it's
time to unite to beat Biden look this
isn't complicated if you want to be the
Republican nominee in 2028 or 2032 or
2036 you're going to have to be able to
credibly stand and say Donald Trump did
a fantastic job as president he tried to
do the best he could for this country he
was unfairly persecuted by the doj and
for that we celebrate him and his
accomplishments and guess what the
voters are actually going to have to
think that you meant what you said now
one of Trump's goto lines on the trail
watch I will never let them take away
your freedom never let them take it
away they want to silence me because I
will never let them silence you and in
the the end they're not after me they're
after you but I just happen to be
standing in their way and I will always
be in their way now that resonates
because it's how many voters feel that
their own government not only doesn't
care about you know them but doesn't
care that their policies are hurting the
middle class they actually think the
government hates them they hate your
values they hate your big mega churches
they hate your big gas guzzling cars
your big families and yeah they don't
even like your patriotism too much but
Trump's message will essentially be
remember when you go to vote for me
you're really voting for
yourselves that will work huge for him
in South Carolina and then it's three
strikes and Nikki's out and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else